[Musique]
bienvenue dans la grande interview
consacrée aujourd'hui à mettre fiodor
rilov il est surnommé l'avocat rouge
l'avocat qui fait trembler les patrons
il défend les ouvriers les laissés pour
compte des fermetures d'usinés les
victimes de licenciements des grands
groupes il a ainsi fait plier psa ou
whirlpool continental samsonite pour ne
citer qu'eux bonjour m rilov merci nous
accorder cet entretien
bonjour on va commencer par parler de
vous vous êtes engagé dès le plus jeune
âge c'est à dire qu'à 17 ans vous êtes
déjà encarté au parti communiste d'où
vous vient cet engagement c'est bien de
votre famille oui il ya évidemment des
origines familiales mais écoutez moi
j'ai toujours voulu être concrètement
dans l'action contre les injustices
voilà c'est une aspiration qui m'est
venue extrêmement jeune et très vite
j'ai compris qu'en exerçant le métier
d'avocat je pouvais vraiment être utile
faire avancer faire bouger les lits de
façon immédiate
et voilà donc c'est ce que je suis en
train de faire autant essayer de faire
alors je vais un peu expliqué le
contexte vous vous défendez donc des
ouvriers des personnes qui ont été
licenciées ou sont menacés d'être
licencié et vous intervenez parfois dans
des salles de congrès pour représenter
ces centaines de salariés comme
l'entreprise est de très grande taille
quels sont vos procès les plus
retentissants écoutez franchement moi
tous les procès dans lesquels je suis
engagé s'articule autour d'enjeux
sociaux économiques politiques qui à
chaque fois me semble majeur parce que
bon je vais pas vous étonner en disant
ça moi je considère que je suis en
première ligne
sur le front de la lutte des classes
voilà eux
quand on m'appelle c'est parce que il ya
des salariés qui sont menacés par un
plan de licenciement
menacé d'une véritable catastrophe
sociale en réalité et ça parce que une
minorité d'actionnaires
souvent ce sont des fonds
d'investissement oui ce sont des
structures institutionnelles qui n'ont
en réalité qu'une seule obsession c'est
augmenter et toujours augmenter leurs
profits et donc la raison pour laquelle
les gens qui font appel à moi s'engage
dans un combat c'est parce que il ya de
l'autre côté une classe ultra
privilégiés qui est prête à sacrifier
l'être humain en réalité pour accroître
encore davantage ses richesses et donc à
chaque fois que j'interviens sur ce
front là pour moi c'est majeur parce que
même si on ne gagne pas toujours
même si on n'atteint pas toujours nos
objectifs on parvient quand même la
plupart du temps à faire bouger les
lignes oui à faire reculer cet
adversaire et donc à chaque pas en avant
je considère qu'on contribue à la
construction d'un rapport de force qui
n'est pas encore aujourd'hui en notre
faveur de manière générale mais voilà
c'est c'est dans cette stratégie là
c'est par cette démarche là qu'on arrive
à peut-être à à changer à bouleverser de
façon fondamentale les choses à changer
de société
alors attendez ne me comprenait pas mal
je suis pas en train de vous dire que on
fera la révolution à coup de procès non
mais oui c'est petite bataille si regard
de la photographie dans son ensemble a
cumulé ces petites batailles peuvent
vraiment contribué à modifier les
rapports de force et donc à chaque fois
je m'élance avec
le même enthousiasme la même volonté
d'en découdre
voilà parce que c'est un combat bien sûr
alors d'ailleurs vous attaquer à des
multinationales qui font pour certaines
des profits et qui pourtant licencie
pourquoi est ce légal
bah écoutez je vais vous surprendre
en réalité ce n'est pas légal
c'est pas légal parce que le droit
social français continue heureusement
hein
malgré les réformes nombreuses pour le
démontrer continue à exiger que à
licenciement économique soit fondée sur
des difficultés de l'entreprise ou du
groupe auquel appartient l'entreprise
il faut théoriquement que l'employeur
qui décide de supprimer des emplois de
licencier des salariés pour des raisons
économiques démontrent qu'il est en
train de subir des difficultés
or bon c'est vrai que dans la plupart
des cas où j'interviens les entreprises
ne subissent pas de difficulté les
entreprises bien au contraire font des
profits monstrueux et donc moins mon
boulot technique c'est d'apporter
méticuleusement la preuve que ces
entreprises ne sont pas du tout en train
de subir une baisse de leur chiffre
d'affaires ou une réduction de leur
résultat opérationnel mais qu' elles
sont sur une pente de croissance et que
c'est pour augmenter encore davantage
leurs bénéfices importants qu'elles ont
décidé de licencier alors donc par
exemple vous pouvez me lisant ça aussi
façon assez facile mais we bleed les
empêcher de licencier vue parce que
c'est us et un de vos levier d'action
vous l'avez fait avec goodyear par
exemple que vous avez bloqué pendant
sept ans est ce que ça marche souvent ça
n'empêchait les entreprises de licencier
alors ça marche de moins en moins pour
une raison simple c'est que depuis
goodyear depuis la fameuse lutte des
goodyear qui effectivement a permis de
stopper un plan de fermeture d'usinés le
plan de la destruction de lusine la
fameuse d'amiens nord depuis cette lutte
absolument emblématique il y a eu de
nombreuses réformes pour vider ma boîte
à outils voilà dès 2013 donc dès que les
goodyear ont pour la première fois
réussi à imposer un jugement qui
vraiment ouvraient la perspective d'un
maintien de l'activité à l'intérieur de
lusine à moyen terme
et bien il y a eu une réforme c'est
françois hollande qui a pris
l'initiative de cette réforme
le 14 juin 2013 exactement je me
souviens bien de la latte et cette
réforme a d'une certaine manière cherché
à empêcher les salariés de recourir à la
justice pour suspendre le plan social
voilà le but poursuivi il y avoir été
pour quelque chose
ben écoutez c'était sa part le dg du bon
oui je pense que les salariés de
goodyear you été pour quelque chose dans
ce sens que ben exemple absolument
formidable qu'ils ont donnée de
résistance de capacité à s'adapter ou
différentes circonstances et à gagner
judiciairement contre cette gigantesque
firme américaine goodyear bat
cet exemple a fait peur et il a fallu
donc de l'autre côté de du côté des
privilégiés modifier la loi pour tenter
de stopper l'élan d'une certaine manière
et oui lorsque monsieur sapin qui était
ministre de l'économie à l'époque est
venu présenter son projet de loi à
l'assemblée nationale il n'a pas
dissimulé que son but c'était de
déjudiciariser les plans sociaux donc de
faire en sorte que les salariés ne
puisse plus faire appel à la justice
pour suspendre la catastrophe qui les
menaçait et il a effectivement cité
l'exemple des goodyear comme étant
l'exemple à ne pas suivre
en tout cas comme étant la bataille qui
va l'avait inspiré pour pour quoi faire
pour faire en sorte que en france on ne
puisse plus arrêter la machine infernale
des plans sociaux avant qu'il ne soit
trop tard
mais croyez moi la réforme de 2013
elle a été suivie d'autres modifications
législatives
ça va toujours dans le même sens et ça
ça ne nous empêche pas de trouver des
moyens de trouver des outils pour
continuer à freiner l'application des
plans sociaux à stopper ses plans de
fermetures d'entreprises qui n'ont
aucune justification
c'est de plus en plus difficile mais on
y arrive encore le gardien exemple en
date c'est la suspension du plan social
général elektriks l'année dernière oui
parfois vous n'arrivez pas empêcher les
licenciements mais vous arrivez à
obtenir des indemnités record comme par
exemple plusieurs dizaines de millions
pour les salariés qui sont restés sur le
carreau
racontez nous oui alors la question de
vous venez de me poser est extrêmement
intéressante parce que c'est là que se
situe
vraiment la ligne de crête biais la
bataille après les licenciements pour
obtenir des indemnités afin que les
salariés touchent une compensation pour
le dommages énormes qu'ils subissent
mais la plupart d'entre eux ne retrouve
pas de boulot il quand il on retrouve
c'est dans des conditions des normes
prêtait précarité mais ça c'est une
question qui pour les grandes firmes se
pose on va dire de manière systématique
parce que lorsque elles licencient elles
vont quasiment toujours provisionné
payer une somme dans la perspective d'un
procès qui serait fait par les salariés
et qui serait couronné de succès et qui
donc amené amènerait ces firmes à payer
des indemnités à ceux qui l'ont licencié
ça c'est quelque chose qu'ils ont trahi
leurs programmes et et je vais pas dire
que ça ne les gêne pas mais c'est d'une
certaine façon un coup qu'ils ont inclus
d emblée dans le programme de la
fermeture des activités qu'ils ont
décidé d'alors s'est nourri mais
finalement ces montants seraient pas
forcément dissuasif alors pour les
entreprises celle ci a coûté 100 m en
tout cas c'est beaucoup beaucoup moins
dissuasif beaucoup moins dissuasif que
une action qui permet de stopper le
processus de licenciement avant qu'il ne
soit trop tard
c'est à dire avant que les lettres de
licenciement ne soit envoyé aux salariés
et est donc à chaque fois qu'il y assez
grand luth la première étape
fondamentale c'est de tenter de faire
obstruction à ce projet de licenciements
massifs
on est de plus en plus mal équipés mais
les salariés sont de plus en plus
déterminés aussi voyez donc c'est pas
parce que la boîte à outils est moins
garni que la détermination des salariés
est la mienne
si pour aller les chercher avant que le
licenciement des dieux et tenter de
stopper le processus s'est amoindrie au
contraire les salariés aujourd'hui sont
de plus en plus mobilisés pour faire en
sorte que le projet n'ait pas lieu
voilà moi je suis là aujourd'hui même en
train de préparer des actions en justice
qui vont te conduire à une audience la
semaine prochaine afin de suspendre un
plan de restructuration dans une usine à
quelques dizaines de kilomètres de paris
et voilà la mobilisation des salariés
croyez moi elle est en augmentation
voilà leur détermination est extrêmement
forte et vraiment notre
détermination à arrêter ces catastrophes
sociales est toujours aussi forte aussi
ou si entières m rilov on va marquer une
courte pause on se retrouve juste après
[Musique]
de retour dans la grande interview avec
m fiodor rilov l'avocat bête noire des
patrons qui défend les ouvriers les
victimes des usines qui ferment m rilov
les multinationales dont on parle et
dispose également d'outils pour faire ce
que bon leur semble comme par exemple de
faux rachat ou autres combines lesquels
sont l eau
écoutez ce sont pas forcément des
combines la démarche générale d'une
grande firme lorsque elle a décidé de
délocaliser par exemple donc de
transférer la production vers un autre
lieu souvent dans un pays où la main
d'oeuvre est beaucoup moins cher ça sa
démarche lorsqu'elle prépare le
licenciement des salariés qui faisait
fonctionner cette activité jusque là
c'est d'abord et avant tout de maquiller
l'information parce que comme je vous
l'indiquais tout à l'heure le droit
social français continuent à exiger que
l'on présente une affiche de difficultés
économiques pour prétendre supprimer des
emplois et licencié des salariés
donc il y a une préparation de la part
de ces firmes de la diffusion d'une
information qui est quasiment toujours
tronquées
c'est à dire que les chiffres qui sont
avancés qui sont montrés aux salariés et
à leurs représentants sont des chiffres
en décalage parfois vertigineux avec les
chiffres que l'on trouve dans la
comptabilité officielle ce qu'on appelle
la comptabilité consolider un qui est
certifié qu'il présentait à
l'administration fiscale et notre
travail c'est justement de dissiper cet
écran de fumée oui et c'est de gratter
le maquillage et de faire émerger la
réalité des profits gigantesques que
réalise ces firmes et c'est vraiment une
enquête qu'on mène il faut avancer et
méticuleusement il faut aller chercher
les sources
souvent ce sont des groupes étrangers
donc les comptes consolidés certifiés ne
sont pas immédiatement disponible en
france donc il faut aller les chercher
dans les sources à l'étranger il ya
toute une bataille autour de
l'information pour faire progressivement
remonter à la surface les véritables
chiffres et une fois qu'on a les
véritables chiffres parfois franchement
chère madame
les bras m'en tombent parce que quand je
compare ce que la firme diffuse comme
information auprès des salariés pour
prétendre que la fermeture de l'usiné
est absolument indispensable est
justifiée parce que il y aurait des
pertes parce que il y aurait une baisse
significative du chiffre d'affaires
quand je compare ça à la réalité de
toutes ces performances extraordinaires
que réalise la firme et que l'on
retrouve dans la comptabilité consolidé
il suffit de regarder deux lignes oui la
ligne du chiffre d'affaires et la ligne
de ce qu'on appelle le résultat
opérationnel c'est-à-dire le profit 1 et
bien le contraste est tellement
gigantesques que on a juste envie que
s'exclamer mais comment peuvent-ils
mentir comme des arracheurs de dents à
ce point oui une fois que évidemment les
documents sont mis sur la table du juge
il lui faut pas longtemps à lui non plus
pour arriver à la conclusion qu'il n'y a
pas de justification valable
licenciement est comme ça donc on gagne
de façon extrêmement régulière mais oui
si d'autre part quand je te conseille de
rachat je pensais à au fait qu'une
entreprise rachète une usine est en fait
en deux ans finalement licencier les
employés mais sans sans indemnisation
d'un unités de d'ancienneté oui alors ça
c'est effectivement un tour de passe
passe que l'on retrouve assez souvent et
que je vais vous détailler dans quelques
instants
mais juste une chose avance la wii en
2013 date fatidique que j'évoquais tout
à l'heure il ya une autre chose qui a
été modifiée par hollande 1 et mâcon
d'ailleurs très récemment aggraver
encore cette modification du code du
travail à savoir qu' on ne peut plus
démontré le caractère totalement faux de
la fiche présenté par la firme et qui
consiste à déplorer des pertes et c'est
qu'ils sont totalement fantaisistes
inexistante 1 on ne peut plus se servir
de ça pour stopper les licenciements
avant qu'il ne soit trop tard avant que
les salariés perdent leur travail et
donc ça procure évidemment beaucoup de
de colère parce que les salariés ne
comprennent pas un monde meilleur non
plus je ne comprends pas comment on peut
démontrer qu'il n'ya aucune raison
valable ou licenciements que tout cela
n'est fait que pour augmenter encore
davantage des profits colossaux et ne
pas pouvoir demander au juge d'en tirer
les conséquences
les plus
logique à savoir interdire à la firme de
continuer à mettre en oeuvre son projet
qui est dépourvue de tout fondement
valable vous vous confirmer que le droit
et le droit du travail et détricoté au
fur et à mesure il est décrite
objectivement détricoter voilà la
déjudiciarisation de ce qu'on appelle
les les plans de restructuration les
pendent aux réorganisations continue
effectivement et et macron est passé à
la vitesse supérieure ma femme fait
aucun rapport de force n'est définitif
et on ne baisse pas les bras
comme je vous ai dit tout à l'heure avec
les instruments dont on continue à
disposer
on se bat et rien n'interdit de croire
que dans un avenir proche on pourra
refaire voter des lois qui vont dans une
direction complètement différente alors
sur le tour de passe passe là que vous
avez évoquées il y à quelques minutes
c'est à dire vendre une entreprise pour
un euro symbolique à de soi-disant
repreneur qui en réalité n'ont pas du
tout l'intention de faire vivre
l'activité de l'entreprise mais qui en
réalité sont rémunérés pour la conduire
à la faillite pour la conduire à la
déconfiture ce tour de passe-passe qui
dit comme ça oui présenté comme ça me
laisse un peu pantois on ne comprend pas
bien quel est l'objectif
mais j'essayais ont très brièvement de
vous expliquer comment ce type
d'opérations permet à des
multinationales
encore une fois extrêmement prospère de
se débarrasser littéralement de
centaines parfois de milliers de
salariés presque sans payer presque sans
avoir à assumer
le moindre coût dans l'opération qui
s'achève donc par un licenciement de
tous ses travailleurs
alors ce qu'il faut comprendre et c'est
vraiment on va dire la clé de voûte de
ce système frauduleux c'est que en
france et est heureusement lorsque les
salariés sont licenciés dans une société
en faillite en liquidation judiciaire
et bien c'est une assurance qui paye les
indemnités de licenciement c'est une
structure qu'on appelle l'assurance
garantie des salaires d'ailleurs tout
salarié sur sa fiche de paye à une ligne
à gs assurances garantie des salaires
et ce sont donc les salariés qui chaque
mois par leur travail et leurs
rémunérations contribuent à alimenter ce
fonds qui est une protection importante
lorsque les salariés perdent leur emploi
dans le cadre d'une déconfiture
sauf que le système est instrumentalisée
par un certain nombre de firmes qui vont
ranger dans une société souvent créées
pour cette opération
ranger dans cette société les activités
et les salariés que la firme souhaite
licencier de la firme souhaite
externaliser comme on dit et une fois
que les activités les salariés sont
ainsi concentrées dans cette société
on va vendre la société pour un euro
voilà vous avez aidé d'une structure
extrêmement importante avec beaucoup de
machines d actifs considérable à
l'intérieur et des centaines de salariés
bien sûr aussi et tout cela est cédé
pour un prix stupéfiants de 1 euro à des
repreneurs qui disent que ils vont
reprendre donc l'activité et la
poursuivre grâce à un plan plus ou moins
convaincante jusque là rien de très
compliqué rien de comment dire d'eux
particulièrement
inédit en revanche ce qui est beaucoup
plus stupéfiant c'est que en parallèle
de cette vente
la firme va donner au repreneur des
sommes gigantesques
voilà ça peut parfois se chiffrer en
centaines de millions en centaines de
millions d'euros
et donc vous avez là tout d'un coup une
opération dans laquelle le vendeur pays
l'acheteur le vendeur de l'entrepris on
a bien compris ses deux fils acheteurs
des dizaines ou des centaines 1 million
d'euros mais l'argument isolé avec cette
thèse avec cette somme
avec cette somme est il une journée
encore pour quelques secondes avec cette
somme
les repreneurs vont se payer a eu une
rémunération considérables pour faire
quoi pour conduire l'entreprise à la
faillite et donc ils vont pendant
plusieurs mois ils vont être extrêmement
subtile et sophistiqué dans la
préparation de quoi de la déconfiture de
la liquidation et une fois que la
liquidation a lieu les salariés sont
tous licenciés au frais qui offraient de
la collectivité parce que c'est
l'assurance garantie des salaires qui
prend en charge le règlement des années
mythes et des sentiments donc assez mal
il ya une pratique qui est de plus en
plus répandue alors monsieur dorilas
vous êtes vous êtes aux premières loges
de la de la désindustrialisation le
gouvernement
a fait beaucoup annoncent déclaration
d'intention pour sauver des usines est
ce que il est vraiment actif dans ce
sens là oui oui il est très très actif
mais il est très actif pour aider les
grandes firmes à fermer les usines v
derrière les larmes de crocodile que
l'on verse à chaque fois qu'il y à une
délocalisation une fermeture d'usiné
vous savez bon les responsables au
niveau départemental au niveau régional
et bien sûr aussi au niveau national se
succèdent à la télévision surtout quand
le plan social et médiatisées où se
succèdent à la radio pour dire à quel
point ils sont scandalisés à quel point
ils vont se mobiliser pour intervenir et
demander des comptes à la grande fille
un bon vous avez vraiment cette attitude
de rituels quasiment aujourd'hui qui est
vraiment déplorable et presque
pathétique parce que quand on regarde ce
qu'ils font concrètement quand on
regarde derrière on s'aperçoit
extrêmement vite que leur intervention
concrète est à l'opposé de ce qu'ils
disent leur intervention concrète c'est
systématiquement de préparer le terrain
d'accompagner ces grandes firmes pour
faire en sorte qu'elles arrivent à
infliger cette catastrophe sociale aux
salariés le plus rapidement possible et
sans qu' il ait à payer des sommes trop
importantes c'est le le gouvernement
français aujourd'hui macron ce ventes à
l'étranger j'ai eu des coups de cela
plusieurs reprises ce ventes à
l'étranger d'avoir totalement transformé
la france pour l'aligner sur les pays
dans lesquels on peut licencier sans
aucun frein il
se félicite concrètement d'être aux
côtés de ce qu'ils appellent les grands
investisseurs étrangers pour les aider à
fermer les usines lorsque ces
investisseurs estiment que la production
en france n'est plus suffisamment
intéressante et qu'il faut délocaliser
l'activité ailleurs donc il ya vraiment
une attitude quasiment 10 aux frais ni
de la part des autorités et en
particulier il faut dire de la part de
maquereaux et de ses affidés qui
aujourd'hui à chaque grand plan social
viennent nous expliquer que ils vont se
mobiliser qui vont faire intervenir
voilà les différentes entités publiques
qui ont des responsabilités en la
matière pour demander des comptes à la
firme alors qu'en vérité ils font encore
une fois exactement le contraire aide
ces firmes les accompagnent et et ils
font en sorte que les salariés en france
perdent leur emploi dans des conditions
de plus en plus misérables je remercie
beaucoup m j'adorais la de nous avoir
parlé de votre carrière votre parcours
auprès des ouvriers que vous soutenez
dans différents plans sociaux je vous
remercie de votre fidélité vous pouvez
retrouver cette émission en replay sur
rt france point tv à bientôt sur arte
france
[Musique]